a three square food bank the sponsor of
this next segment is back to spread the
word about how they're helping our
seniors stay fed and how you can help
take a look
lisa welcome back to the show
thank you so much for having me again of
course we always love having you on
because you tell us such important
information about our community
especially our seniors you guys are
running your your nevada senior hunger
awareness campaign so tell us more about
that sure we are actually so excited we
have partnered up with the food bank of
northern nevada where there's only two
food banks in nevada so we're teaming up
and we're trying to get the word out
that we're actually one of the um in the
top 10 worst states in all of the united
states for having senior hunger be an
issue so we know that we have a lot of
work that needs to get done
absolutely and you've mentioned before
spending trade-offs what are you seeing
seniors having to decide on
financially
yeah unfortunately we know right here in
our city over 50 000 seniors at least
once or twice a year are having to
decide do i pay for rent or do i pay for
food do i pay for my life saving
medication or do i pay for food and you
know we know a lot of people
unfortunately in our town right now are
making these hard decisions uh just
because of the pandemic but for seniors
pre-pandemic and post-pandemic they
actually have to make these decisions
all the time because they lived on fixed
income there's no more money coming in
i can't imagine having to juggle between
choosing what to pay for there so thank
you for that service for sure and where
can people find more information and how
to help you guys
sure um well so the good news is that we
can actually end senior hunger together
so visit our website threesquare.org and
there's all sorts of opportunities on
there you can volunteer you can donate
um but most importantly you might know
somebody maybe your neighbor someone
that you go to church with they might
need help or maybe you need help
call a call center at 702-765-4030
and kind caring advocates are standing
by to help you find the right program
for you with your help you know we don't
want to tell you what program you need
to be in but we're going to say you have
options here's what they look like and
let us know what's going to fit best for
your life and what kind of services do
you guys provide for our seniors you
know outside of this campaign in
particular
great question we actually are really
proud to offer things like free lift
rides and bus passes um two things in
our community like community and
congregate meals because we know that uh
seniors need a lot of options right now
and we want you to get out of your home
if you can and go socialize at a meal
safely of course with masks on and
things like that but we're making sure
all of our sites are safe but in
addition we offer
home delivery free home delivery and
curbside pickup for our grocery program
golden groceries that's great all right
well thank you so much lisa we
appreciate you guys thank you
thank you for sponsoring this segment
three food square bank you can find them
at north pecos road for more information
just call
702-765-4030 or visit threesquare.org
we'll be right back